supreme court justice stephen breyer had
long rejected viewing the high court
through a political lens at first
dismissing calls from democrats to step
down so that a president of their own
party may name a replacement if the
public sees judges as politicians in
robes it's confidence in the courts and
in the rule of law itself can only
diminish
diminishing the court's power
including its power to act as a check on
other branches born in 1938 in san
francisco breyer grew up in a middle
class jewish family he said his
upbringing helped develop the pragmatism
that later shaped his legal views hi
stephen breyer do you solemnly swear he
was a federal appeals court judge for 14
years before president bill clinton
nominated him to the supreme court in
1994
every judge's particular obligation is
to deal fairly and thoroughly with the
legal problems of the individual parties
before the court whether they are poor
or rich or helpless or powerful minority
or a majority briar joined the court's
liberal wing consistently ruling in
favor of abortion rights environmental
protection and voting rights he opposed
the strict textual interpretation of the
u.s constitution as endorsed by
conservatives but he believed in
compromise and was a famous optimist
justice breyer i think is
a true technocrat in the best sense of
the word he believes in
good ideas
thoughtful compromises
and intelligence and expertise
running the world
and
he has really tried to do that quite
consistently
in his time on the court
in his later years on the court breyer
questioned the legality of the death
penalty and drafted one of the rulings
of holding obamacare his retirement now
sets up a political battle to name a
replacement
heidi jo castro al jazeera washington